- Hello.
Good afternoon, I'm Alice Kaplan,
Director of the Whitney Humanities Center.
Thank you to the Department of French
for joining the Whitney as a co-sponsor
of Juliette Cherbuliez's
"Medea: A Manifesto."
Juliette Cherbuliez is the Director
of the Center for Premodern Studies
and a professor of French at
the University of Minnesota.
A comparatist, she's
published on the materiality
and politics of women's
writing in early modern France,
tragedy, violence, and visual culture.
Her most recent book
interrogates these concepts at their core.
"In the Wake of Medea:
Tragedy and the Arts of
Destruction in Neoclassical France"
is at the heart of her talk today.
I want to mention too her previous book,
"The Place of Exile:
Leisure Literature and
the Limits of Absolutism."
Here, she's concerned with writers
who are not considered
explicitly political,
banished noblewomen,
novelists, and poor refugees
who sought out a space
for writing and living
beyond Louis XIV's absolutist reach.
In both of these books,
Juliette explores what she calls
the lost opportunities of
the early modern period,
concepts, themes, ideas
that did not become part of our modernity.
She asks questions that
challenge many commonplaces,
that look at what has been overlooked,
that revolutionize our point of view
on concepts we think we know.
The political, for example.
Through her original
and powerful readings,
Juliette Cherbuliez shows
that figures of the early modern period
are essential to our own thought,
and at the same time, she
underscores their otherness,
so that we not project our
own categories onto them.
Before we welcome Juliette,
please note that she'll be back
with us this coming Monday,
February 21st at 4:30
as part of the "Uprooting
Medea" presentation
featuring visiting artist Shivaike Shah,
who will discuss his production
of Euripides' Greek tragedy
with an all-multicultural cast and crew.
Shiv will be in
conversation with Juliette,
along with Yale faculty
Christina Kraus in Classics
and Eric Glover in the School of Drama.
And we're putting a
registration link in the chat.
After Juliette's talk,
we'll have a few minutes for
questions from the audience,
so please put your questions
in the Q and A panel,
and feel free to submit your questions
at any time during the talk.
Juliette, welcome to the
virtual French department
and Whitney Humanities Center.
Let's get started.
- Alice, thank you so much
for that warm introduction
and to the invitation from
the Whitney Humanities Center.
I also heartily thank Pierre Saint-Amand
and your colleagues in
the French department.
While it is really unfortunate for me
that I am not in New Haven today,
this virtual encounter recalls to me
times really not that long ago
of mobility, conviviality, and
shared intellectual projects.
In fact, my last professional trip,
weeks before the pandemic hit,
involved work with
Professor Maurice Samuels.
My last international
conference was in Fribourg,
organized by Professor Christophe Schuwey,
and so in so many ways, this
talk marks for me anyway,
a (speaks in foreign language),
a taking back up of
conversations forestalled.
There's one intellectual exchange
which not even a global
calamity could stop,
and that is the one I've had
with Associate Director of
the Whitney Humanities Center
Diane Berrett Brown,
and for her contributions
realizing this event,
I am deeply grateful,
but for her generosity,
grace, and unending smarts
that have informed my work
for nearly two decades,
I'm really indebted.
So, it's a real pleasure to be with you,
with all of you here today.
I hope you can see my screen.
The images are pretty key to this talk.
There is a type of news
photo that has haunted me,
perhaps you too, for about
the past five, six years.
This one might be the
most amazing example,
but there are many iterations
of this composition
and the confrontation it records.
They capture events all over,
from Chile in 2016, to Moscow in 2019,
to my adopted city of Minneapolis
from just two summers ago,
and again this past summer.
There are other more
bureaucratic versions of this.
They represent a type, that
of a girl or young woman
standing up to institutional power
in North America and elsewhere,
especially the Global South,
often a black or brown girl.
So often a young woman not
from a dominating class.
We have been taken by
surprise for a long time
by the reality of girl power
as an ideal of political contestation,
but also of gendered
resiliency as we can see
in the astonishing assertion
that "Females are strong as hell,"
to quote the title sequence
from Netflix's "Unbreakable
Kimmy Schmidt,"
a show which when you think about it
explores how PTSD from
15 years of kidnapping,
brainwashing, misogyny, and abuse
can help a young woman from the
Midwest make it in New York.
I do understand why we want
heroes, ideal people of action.
What makes these people
particularly heroic?
Generally, we don't know or ask
what happens after these photos.
It's the stance of defiance
itself that we admire.
I can't help but come back
to this one of Ieshia Evans,
which displays the
contradictions of an encounter
between the older, seemingly
older, versus the younger,
the overly weaponized
powerful and protected
versus the unarmed and vulnerable,
the many versus the singular.
It is the stillness and strength,
that resilient statuesque
position here of Ieshia Evans
against the seemingly
choreographed dance of power.
It is that which I call
the Antigone effect.
Antigone has been the
darling of political theory
since arguably the 18th century.
She is, fitting to our story of modernity,
an icon of political hope,
even as she embodies tragic failure
from her obstinate and fearless conviction
that she must do right by
her rebel brother's corpse
and bury it in the face
of a royal interdiction,
through her self-generated peerlessness
as she refuses accomplices or partners,
especially her truth-telling
in the king's face.
"Yes," Antigone says to Creon,
"I did it. I am guilty."
And finally, most poignantly,
to her lament about her foreclosed future
before she is taken away to be walled up,
where she is found having hanged herself.
Antigone is constituted as
a paragon of the individual,
whose allegiances to her
particular familial sacred duties
compel her to test the state's
power and deny its hegemony.
There's something surely here
about the pure potential
of youth, to be sure.
If you do attempt to do an
internet search of, for example,
"old women resist power," or
"old women against police,"
or "old woman as icon of
resistance," you don't find much.
If you try really, really hard,
you come up with this one.
Note that she is walking away.
My favorite part of this
is actually the handbag.
But it can't all be about youth.
The Antigone effect I refer
to owes its enduring appeal,
it seems, rather to a complex of features.
To try another tack at that effect,
and with a nod to the central
subject of my remarks today,
a search for an analogous Medea effect
yields very different results.
This is Peter Ward's 2009 book,
asserts that life on Earth
tends towards simplicity, not complexity,
so involves fundamentally
self destruction.
Medea's also the name of
a gene in a fruit fly,
and as an acronym, it's also the name
of an effect of another gene,
which has both a toxin and its antidote.
So those of you familiar
with Medea's story
know why these results concern
the fundamental act of a
life-giver taking life.
Euripides made her famous for
having killed her children,
but a full transhistorical
consideration of Medea
must however include
how she also betrays
her father and kingdom,
hacks her brothers into pieces,
causes the death of her husband's uncle
at the hands of his own daughters,
destroys a city having caused
the poisoned burning deaths
of its king and princess.
Despite, and maybe because of
all these gruesome actions,
I am interested in what is to
be gained by offering Medea
the same attention we
have lavished on Antigone.
If you came to this talk
from the Schwarzman Center,
from the advertisement,
I shall say that you may
be a little disappointed,
because I am certainly
not here to promote Medea
as a salutary icon of positive action,
but I am deeply interested in this figure
as a political figure,
and a figure of politics.
And what follows comes
from my most recent book,
which treats the specific case of violence
in the 17th century
through the lens of what
I call Medean violence,
and I'll come to an example
from that book in a little bit,
but today I wanna discuss
how Antigone is conceived of
in our political imagination first,
and then I will return to
Medea, that "icon of horrorism,"
as philosopher Adriana
Cavarero has called her,
and why I think she might
be a more important model
for a future politics.
Okay, so, Antigone and Medea
have one major aspect in common.
Each contests the authority of the state
at the time of its formation.
This is true in nearly every version.
Oh, here is my book.
I think we can move on from there, though.
This contestation of the
state at its formation
is true in nearly every version,
and here are two of my favorites.
Of course, the details
of this contestation
and the warrants each makes
for her sense of justice
differ almost diametrically.
Antigone is a virgin who
grieves, contests, and dies.
Medea is a mother who
travels, kills, and lives on.
Antigone wishes to honor
her brother with a burial.
Medea chops her brother, Apsyrtus,
into bits to delay her father's pursuit,
compelling him to recover
the pieces for burial.
Antigone laments her father's curse,
whereas Medea carries with her
the knowledge bequeathed
to her through her house,
which includes not just the sun,
but masters of the
occult Circe and Hecate.
While, for example, this
is Judith Butler's argument
about promiscuous obedience,
Antigone challenges a
certain kind of family,
revealing the origins
of kingship and kinship
as both arbitrary,
Medea underscores precisely
the opposite logic,
the steadfast power of family,
whether chosen, Jason,
or imposed, her children.
Following this logic,
Medea traces the promise not of origins,
but of the ambiguity of the future.
It is crucial that no matter
what destruction Medea wreaks,
she flies off alive, she's never killed,
to live on and perhaps then to return.
So while Antigone stands
for "a future interrupted,"
to borrow from Bonnie Honig,
Medea is an exemplar
at once of an archaism,
a kind of premodernity we cannot overcome,
and a future absolutely
guaranteed to arrive,
but whose consequences we cannot foretell.
So, Antigone.
Exercising her private
familial and sacred task
of burying the dead against
the emergent ordering
of the force of the city,
this young and unmarried
childless daughter of Oedipus
has come to represent
that force of domesticity,
the right of privacy, and the family
against the overreaching state,
the perils and potential
of individual resistance,
and, we shouldn't forget,
the special kind of powerless power
of women in the modern state,
which has so often been a
test case for the individual
inalienable right to self-determination.
But, has it been effective to
assign a young, aristocratic,
apparently-gendered female all our hopes?
It seems that Antigone has
become in our contemporary time
less a model of political action
and more one of our inability
to marshal a clear and enduring vision
of what both the morality and
the politics of resistance
should look like today.
Sophocles' play has
furnished us with the grounds
for imagining the
individual political subject
obeying laws that are
higher, older, and broader
than those of the state,
even at that individual's peril.
Antigone performs this function
as early as the 18th century.
Consistent with Europe's
rumblings against monarchism
and toward liberal democracy,
Louis de Jaucourt,
the "Encyclopedie's"
most prolific contributor
and an expert on legal
matters and jurisprudence,
even gives Antigone the last word
in his article on the political subject.
Refuting Hobbes's argument
about loyal subjects
working as instruments of the sovereign
and therefore bearing no responsibility
for the justice of their actions,
Jaucourt cites the
tragedy's most oft-cited
and famous scene,
the stichomythia standoff
between Antigone and Creon,
and he ends his article with this.
So he gives Antigone the last word.
So from the mid 18th century on,
it is this duologue,
Antigone's challenge to
and refutation of Creon's authority
over her private sacred duties,
which has become a touchstone
for Hegel, Lacan, Irigaray, Judith Butler,
and again, to a certain
extent, Bonnie Honig.
As a scholar of performance and theater,
I find this move extracting Antigone
from the network of
relations and interactions
which constitute her and her community
within the play reductive.
Our ideal Antigone has become an Antigone
who defies and contests,
whereas in Sophocles' play,
she is also an Antigone
who primarily takes action
by burying her brother.
That is to say the tragedy,
even when driven by song and declamation
as the art was for Sophocles
in the fifth century
before the Common Era,
is not just about its words.
It is also about the
deeply material relations
and physical gestures that bind us.
Tragedy is by design and in performance
neither monologic nor based on soliloquy,
not a medium of icons or figures,
but one in which it is precisely
the relations among characters,
or the tensions among individual
and collective significations
that are explored.
The tragedy "Antigone" is, after all,
a play about people burying people.
The initial tension in the
play comes from a debate
about who buried a corpse,
and whether one should bury a corpse.
The plummeting shock
at the end of the play,
when Antigone's own body
causes an avalanche of other deaths,
her beloved Haemon, who's also
Creon's son, kills himself,
Haemon's mother the queen
then kills her herself,
which signals the fragility
of Creon's own family
and therefore of the state.
This is an account of action after action.
The best model for the tragedy Antigone
is not the fight of words
such as those between Creon and Antigone,
but the consequences of
individual actions on a community.
While some have bemoaned
what they call the necropolitics
of the tragedy, "Antigone,"
sorry, of the tragedy "Antigone,"
what makes me most
nervous about its eponym,
Antigone the character,
is rather two other aspects
she's come to inhabit.
First, I am wary of the ways
we find Antigone hopeful,
despite her death, despite
the death she brings.
Not only do I think this is a confusion
of potential with efficacity,
it also puts the burden of
future change on individuals,
as if the underlying structures,
the polis in which she
debates and maneuvers,
to borrow from Bonnie Honig again,
has always been constituted as such
and could never be anything but.
My last complaint is this.
How is it possible that
Antigone meets Creon one-on-one?
It is astonishing that she might do so,
because she's young,
because she's defiant,
because she seems honest,
rigorous, uncompromising,
but it's because she is
Creon's future daughter-in-law,
because she is his niece,
because she is a member
of the House of Thebes,
because she is aristocratic
that she may stand to contest Creon's law,
and that she may bury her brother,
and that she may marry
or even forsake Haemon.
Antigone is of the polis,
and she is of the family,
and it is by virtue of
these ancient rights,
these innate entitlements, that she can,
sacrificing herself, destabilize the city.
This points again to my discomfort
with our appreciation of
all those media images
of mostly of women of color
standing strong in their resiliency.
These are not images of
how power really works.
These are images many can appreciate
without suffering the consequences,
either personally or structurally.
What then, if our notion
of the political subject
did not depart from
an aristocratic, youthful subject
who is of the reigning house?
Might we need to more radically
redraw our political family tree
by considering the vagaries of geography,
conquest, inheritance, and affiliation?
To do so might compel
us to reconsider who,
and whose stories, constitute
the House of Thebes,
and who has been excluded from the polls
as a feature of its constitution.
What if we contended
with the very conditions
that the tragedy "Antigone" inlies?
After all, that tragedy
starts in the aftermath of war
and finishes with the regret
for a death not spared
and bodies strewn all about.
What if the story of politics
included the statelessness
that war brings home, the
persistence of revenge,
the state's monopoly of force,
and the problem of women who
do not die, but rather kill?
Or, to put it better, who
kill and yet do not die.
In sum, the question
of the role of violence
in the formation and
maintenance of society.
Appropriate to her final entombment,
Antigone's name means, as
Anne Carson reminds us,
"against birth," or,
"instead of being born."
We might hope that Medea's name
might mean "against the mother,"
or, "instead of childbearing,"
since she has been so
intimately associated
with mothers who are selfish
and who kill their offsprings
or otherwise eat life.
And while Antigone's final words
are a lament about never
marrying or having children,
Medea's major lament decries
the pain of childbirth,
and contrasts it with the
trivial wounds of war.
Medea's name means rather
"intelligent planner," or "contriver."
It derives from the
Indo-European root "med-"
which Emile Benveniste defines as
"to take authoritatively those measures
which are appropriate."
The first syllable of
Medea shares the same root
as meditate or medicine.
Medea's careful deployment of knowledge
names the same authoritative care
as that informing then
deep study or healing.
This is why she is so
often portrayed as a witch.
This ambiguity might explain
why the most common
visual depiction of her
in premodern iconography
is the rejuvenation of
Aeson, Jason's father.
Or, is it that of Medea
killing Jason's usurping uncle Pelias?
The gestures are similar
enough to give one pause,
and to make explicit the connection
between healing and killing.
You can hear here echos of
Jacques Derrida's pharmakon
as the medium for
language's undecidability.
So the pharmakis, the
wizard, the magician pioneer
always encounters its homophone pharmakos,
that exiled, sacrificed
scapegoat sent out of the city
and ritually killed as a purification and,
as Derrida says, a remedy
for the polis.
Medea is both at once.
She is exiled from her
own land of Colchis,
so a foreigner in Corinth.
She will also fly away from Corinth
and be a foreigner wherever she goes.
She has knowledge that is
deemed unnatural to the Greeks
because it is foreign and potent.
Her estranged position is
geopolitical and epistemological.
In Medea's actions,
the knowledge of healing
and killing are linked,
as are magician and exile.
Two likenesses of Medea speak volumes
about this confluence
of knowledge and exile.
They're both on Roman sarcophagi
from the mid to late second century.
Both show Medea depicted
as herbalist or arsonist,
connecting the science
of knowing and making
with the elemental reality of
combustion and distribution.
Each depicts the story of Jason and Medea
from the theft of the Golden Fleece
to the death of the children,
and the story is told
on three or four sides,
I'm forgetting now, but it,
it follows the sides of the sarcophagus.
And you can see right in
the middle of this one,
you can see an amalgam
of both of these crimes,
the theft of the Fleece and
the death of the children,
with the death of Creusa,
which I'll point out using my cursor,
which I hope you can
see, right in the middle,
the death of Creusa after having donned
a poisoned robe gifted
by Medea for her wedding.
This first one is at the
Basel Museum of Antiquities.
You can see on the left
the children bringing the
robe to the bride Creusa,
who will be marrying Jason.
You can see on the right
Medea in her chariot,
flying away with a child
slung over her shoulders.
And the other one is in there too.
At the center, Creusa as if in movement,
is as if in movement,
her own hand stretched
out in front of her.
She's running away from the gown
that clings to and will kill her.
Her father cries out in back of her.
And underneath her left
knee is a box or a stool,
ordained with tragic masks.
Even more discreetly, behind
the two children to her right,
there is another box, hardly
visible in this image,
but art historians of Rome confirm,
it is a metonym for the absent Medea,
it is the case in which
she keeps her herbs.
The second sarcophagus,
now at Berlin's new museum of antiquities,
is sparser than Basel's,
so we're even more immediately drawn
to the Creon-Creusa couple,
who, despite the available space,
this sarcophagus is much less
populated than the other one,
despite that available space
are even closer together here,
his curly beard nearly
touching her flowing locks.
The power of Medea is expressed
not by such accessories as boxes,
but through the metamorphosis
of Creusa's hair,
that symbol of virginity,
and often as it flows before
marriage and shearing, youth,
into, sorry, a symbol of femininity,
and often before shearing in marriage,
the symbol of youth and virginity,
and you can see that Creusa's
hair is turning into flames.
Part of it, here's a closeup,
part of it reaches skyward,
touching the frame,
as does Creusa's hand.
Medea's actions, whether
she's depicted as an herbalist
or an arsonist,
connect the science of knowing and making
with the elemental reality of
combustion and destruction.
I have wondered a lot
about why I continue to think alongside
a figure of such destruction
and calculated harm.
It comes back to the now classic analysis
offered by Bruno Latour in the early 1990s
regarding what he calls
the modern constitution,
that agreement made to
distinguish absolutely
between nature and society,
between humans and non-humans.
Medea thematizes a violation
of this modern constitution,
or perhaps she is simply,
as I argue in the book, always premodern.
Her very old and foreign knowledge
inherited from the sun
is what confirms her
as an interloper in the Greek world,
who cannot be assimilated.
That reminds us that
Medea is on the outside,
both of a Latourian constitution
and that of the polis.
Medea is doubly foreign.
She comes from another place,
but she also imports and mobilizes
another way of ordering the world.
This is what I've come to think of
as epistemological alterity,
when what and how one
knows contravenes the laws
of nature and the polis,
such as the locals have established them.
With epistemological alterity
there is no assimilation.
A quick example from
the many I might offer
from the theater of 17th century France,
that most classic of centuries,
according to traditional
canon and periodization,
the apogee of absolutism
where order reigned so supreme
that even tragedy
eventually was disciplined
within an inch of its
aesthetic life, as it were.
Strict conventions came to prohibit
any display of passion
on the tragic stage,
as a matter of decency.
Thus, when Pierre Corneille
oversees the publication
of his complete works in 1660,
each play is accompanied not
by a representation of a scene
that was acted onstage,
but ones that were of such violence
that they were recounted and described,
but not actually played out.
So here on the left from "Horace,"
the battle scene between
the Horaces and the Curiaces
exemplifies this editorial strategy.
It's reported three times in the play,
as if happening just offstage.
The tragedy of "Medee," on the right,
is the exception to this rule.
This is the final scene where Medee,
having destroyed the city
and killed her children,
is riding off in her chariot,
and Jason is left on
the ground in Corinth.
I could talk a lot about why
Corneille and his printers
deviated from this program
and printed a scene
that is actually played
in the play itself,
but instead I wanna
return to another image
of this same scene.
This one is from 1664.
It is from another complete edition
of the theater of Pierre Corneille,
and I'm just gonna blow
it up a little bit.
It is borrowing from the
1660 edition in composition,
but certainly not in technique.
You maybe you can see that
it's much less capable,
not as nice detail, not as well printed.
This is an unauthorized
version of Corneille's work
printed and sold in Amsterdam.
This is an addition that for centuries,,
up until decades ago,
was routinely omitted from
scholarly bibliographies
of Corneille's work,
since it was considered a counterfeit,
despite that term being both
completely anachronistic and inaccurate.
So 19th and 20th century
scholars perpetuated in some ways
the 17th century's own borders,
as if a Dutch printer could
not print a French text,
or if he did so was in a
certain way transgressive
or in excess.
Let's look more carefully
at some of the other
excesses of this image.
Let me see if I can get there.
Jason is still stage right,
while further upstage two
bodies remain visible.
One is on the ground.
The forms are indistinct
so that they are not meant,
so who they're meant to
be can only be inferred.
Medee is in her dragon-drawn chariot,
although this one is
drawn by someone else.
What is remarkably different in this image
is the prominence of destruction.
We can see that the clouds
bearing the chariot,
that appear in both images,
in the Amsterdam images are clearly clouds
from the burning building.
And in fact, the destruction in this image
is far more explicit.
And let's see if I can
get a closeup there.
There we go.
Corinth is not only still
shown to be burning,
flames escape the palace's orifices,
but even a skeleton peeks out
from the fire above the doorway, grinning,
perhaps at the witnesses who are pointing,
who are standing below pointing upward,
whether to it or to Medee.
The Amsterdam image is an apt
symbol for Medean violence.
A non-authorized version
created and circulated
just beyond its author's
sphere of influence
and also outside of the
confines of the monarchy
for which classical tragedy
would be set to work.
It also figures the scale, scope,
and quality of Medean violence,
and its legacy in and beyond Corneille.
Much like this Amsterdam
image, for many critics,
the violence of this
myth is explained in part
by the constitution of its eponym.
Medee the character remains
an outsider, unassimilable,
whether of female power
or of non-European
cultures and knowledges.
While Antigone stands inside
or outside of the city,
the figure of Medea has no
warrant to be wherever it is.
Here again she is, children in tow,
the dragon's snakelike body
curling through the chariot's wheel.
Regular technology is
useless for this flight.
The snake's sinuating catch in the wheels
will also remind me that while Antigone
remains peerless and
absolute in her conviction,
Medea has no moral purity to stand on
and so offers no moral lesson.
Always a foreigner,
always carrying with and carried
by its foreign knowledge,
the figure of Medea inserts
itself into our community,
whether we want it there or not.
And while Antigone dies alone,
Medea lives, kills, and lives on.
Medea's modus operandi is a
cleaving to and from others,
a politics of attachments and detachment,
which offers a radical model,
ordering politics according
to relations among people,
not by vesting the individual
in its own license.
Finally then, Medea indicates the extent
to which our political order,
liberal democracy based on
self-possessed individualism,
is predicated on the exclusion
not just of certain actors,
but of certain knowledges.
Oh, I said I would offer you a manifesto,
and I think I've only done so in part.
The problem is, what now?
I am not standing here
on a rhetorical rampart
urging you to follow me.
Medea has, I've said several times,
no lesson to offer, and nor do I.
I maintain that liberal
democracy's celebration
of the peerless individual
has let us astray,
but if you were waiting
for me to torch this place
and then kill my daughter,
you have misread me entirely.
Rather, I've tried to suggest
that the violence of Medea
is in many ways here to stay
because of how we have constituted
both the city and its heroes.
Medea's violence is also that
of the figure's sense of history.
It is relational.
It is embedded.
I think we need to seek a
politics that acknowledges
that relational, that embedded,
the fundamental injustice and untenability
of a city carved out of the
included and the excluded.
Perhaps also then we need
to emancipate ourselves,
not just from giving all
our hopes to Antigone,
but also to stop thinking
that we can imagine a world
without any Medeas,
or that the violence we know
that exists in the world
can and should be kept
away, outside, over there.
In nearly every version
of her tale, I've said,
Medea flies away, never
captured or eliminated.
If we built a politics
based on her sure return
and her inevitable inclusion
into our ways of being and knowing,
what then would our cities look like?
Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
My goodness, I'm kind of, I'm reeling
as I contemplate the incredible
paradox of your title.
So I can't really ask you
what this politics of
Medea would look like,
but maybe I can ask you what we,
and you might just be repeating
from the brilliant talk,
but what do we lose?
What do we lose when we
choose Antigone over Medea?
- Oh, that's a really wonderful question.
I think when we choose
Antigone over Medea,
I think, I guess maybe I'm not
going to put it as a choice,
if I can answer that question
a little differently.
I think what happens when
we've chosen Antigone
is we've caught ourselves
into a model that says
political resistance takes the form,
in some ways, of a sacrifice,
and it costs the city very little
to accept that as a form
of political resistance.
- Right, 'cause the political agent
has bumped themselves off, right?
So no problem.
- Yes, yeah.
Yes, and I think that we,
I showed all those images
because I think it's so wonderful
to see those images of defiance,
but we're also trapping people in a bind,
a bind that women of
color often point out,
that their strength and their resiliency
is seen as somehow
miraculous and superhuman,
and yet situations don't change for them,
and I think it's really important
to complement that very
famous image from 2016
of Ieshia Evans with the one
where she's being taken away,
because she does get arrested.
And I think this idea,
this idea of Medea as a
heroine also puts an undue,
the she's been constituted,
because I think this is,
in part what I'm trying to suggest is
there's a history in the
modern era about these figures
that doesn't belong to the premodern era,
and Antigone has been
constituted in the modern era
as somebody who contests and debates,
and I think it diminishes
the fact that she also acts,
and that all tragedies,
even when they're constituted by words,
are also about the dilemmas
that our actions cause us.
And that's where I think
Medea brings to the fore,
so I guess I wouldn't,
I've used Antigone as a
strawman of some kind,
although I think that
the problem of Antigone
is really important.
So, I hope that
answers something.
- Yeah no, that's very,
it's very interesting,
and I can see why you're resisting
the one-on-one comparison.
- Mmhm.
- We've got a question here.
"I'm intrigued by your claims about Medea
and the steadfast power of family,
even as she kills many of them,
especially your take that
the status of the family
speaks more to the ambiguity of the future
than the power of origins.
It's such a commonplace
to think of family as
inextricable from origins.
Could you say more about this move
connecting Medea to an ambiguous future?
'Manifesto' seemed very future-looking,
so it seems like a key move."
- Yeah, and I did cop to the fact that
I might have failed to
give you a manifesto, but,
and that question is actually
really, really complicated,
so maybe I'll take that first part,
the claim about Medea and the
steadfast power of family,
even if she kills many of them.
So, one of the things I think that we
perhaps don't appreciate as much...
Let me answer this in a different way.
I was just about to dig
myself into a terrible hole.
So Medea, I will take an example of one of
my most favorite versions of Medea,
which is the Pier Paolo Pasolini version,
where when Medea kills her children,
she sings them a lullaby,
puts them to bed,
and then kills them with a knife.
And the scene is a scene of immense care,
of immense tenderness.
One doesn't quite see regret in her face.
And if you haven't seen this movie,
it's a really extraordinary movie.
And so Medea, my claim about Medea
is that Medea is very
tuned to those relations,
and uses them.
The word I use in the book is cleaving,
cleaving to and cleaving from.
She knows how to make people join
who maybe should not be stuck together,
so Creon and Creusa stick
together through the burning robe,
Creon will eventually perish
from that same poisoned robe,
and she also cleaves her
own children from herself.
And what I mean to draw attention to
with that analysis
is that Medea pays attention
to our networked relations,
and of course, family
is at the heart of that.
So I think that family is
inextricable from origins,
and I think Medea confirms that,
but her uprootedness, her foreign status,
also then brings to light the
question of the chosen family.
The father of her children is Jason,
and he chooses to marry somebody else.
So where, what is the status of family?
That's a problem,
that's a problem in the
ancient world as well,
as well as in the premodern world.
So these are the kinds of
questions that the Medea myth asks
that the Antigone myth
never, never needs to ask us.
And in fact, Antigone refuses
a relationship with her sister,
she refuses complicity with her sister.
So it's also about what's exacerbated,
and, you know, what's put pressure,
what the myths put pressure on
and how our inventions of them
exacerbate those pressures.
- Mm, mm. Okay.
Another question.
"Thank you so much for
this wonderful talk.
So many questions. Here's one.
Is there a way to measure
the actual effect,
effectiveness, efficacy,
of Medea's representations
on a given society?
For example, is there a way to measure
how performances of Corneille's 'Medea'
transformed the sociopolitical fabric
of early modern France?
What kind of archives,
or type of evidence,
or even method could we use?
- Oh, my goodness, that's
such a hard question!
(Juliette laughs)
Well, the method I use in my book
is to think about not Medea the myth,
Medea the myth appears
scattered throughout the 17th century,
whereas there's very little Antigone.
In fact, I'm,
there's some Antigone, but not frontally,
whereas Medea, but the term
that I used in the book
is to think about this notion
of a persistence of violence
that is, seems to be a rehearsal
of the impossibility of violence
evacuation from society.
So I take Medean violence
as a form of violence
that I think is constitutive of society.
So, how would I measure the effectiveness
of Medea's representation
on a given society?
Well, I don't think I would,
I'm not sure that that's how
literary representations work,
but I'll one thing about this.
American members of the
audience might be familiar
with Thomas Noble's
really famous painting,
just before the Civil War,
depicting a runaway
slave, Margaret Garner,
who was captured and
killed her two children
so that they would not
be returned to slavery.
And Thomas Noble, this was
a great abolitionist cause
in the United States,
and Thomas Garner made a
painting that was printed,
and that was circulated
in popular magazines like "Harper's,"
and really was a key image for abolition.
And he titled that painting
"A Modern Day Medea."
And Garner was an abolitionist.
That was not a shock
at her having killed her
children, at her infanticide,
that was an acknowledgement
of the disgusting moral
conundrum that she was placed in.
So we can measure in some ways
what Medea means in society,
but I'm not sure I could
put a science to that
in the way that I think
the question is asking me.
I need to think about that a
little bit more. Thank you.
- So this is a question
from my ignorance of classical
theater, but is it true,
you were showing the Corneille images
where there's actually
violence on the stage, so,
does Medea manage to
unsettle the bienseance
of no violence onstage,
just because you can't really,
you can't do it offstage?
- You know, I'm going to say she doesn't.
So, "Medee" is actually performed,
"Medee" is the tragedy that
happens before "Le Cid,"
and "Le Cid" is that play
that generates that whole
discussion about bienseance,
and out of which
bienseance kind of emerges.
However, there is, for the insiders,
for the 17th century insiders amongst us,
I'll just say that what
Professor Kaplan's referring to
is this huge debate in
the early mid 17th century
about what's possible to perform onstage,
and this notion of bienseance,
propriety is one way of
translating that, came up,
and violence onstage is just unseemly,
we can't do it.
And Corneille says, "Do
you know what is seemly?
It's what the audience wants."
He really believes
that we should be listening
to what audiences want,
and not telling them.
And in those pamphlet wars that occur
around this other play, "Le Cid,"
Corneille prints for the
first time his "Medee."
1639, he prints it.
And so he launches "Medee" as
a firebomb into those debates.
I do think that the
outcome of those debates
was a gradual normative evacuation
of the passions and
violence from the stage,
but what replaced it was
incredibly vivid descriptions
that are quite disgusting
if you read them carefully.
And so in some ways there
is this transmutation
of hypotyposis, of vivid imagery,
on the 17th century stage
that's quite breathtaking.
So I don't think that
violence ever goes away,
I just don't think it's possible.
- Yeah, I mean, it's a
wonderful issue that goes forth
into modern literature
with the whole question of restraint and,
you know, ellipsis,
and why you don't see Julien
Sorel at the guillotine
and things like that.
It's wonderful.
Okay, questions are coming
faster and faster, here's one.
"Are we reinterpreting Medea's story
in the context of the modern era,
or are we rediscovering themes
that would've been more
obvious to ancient readers?"
- Oh, that is-
- I'm not sure what "we" means.
Is, I don't know, "we" in the context of-
- So I'll say what I am doing.
In part, I think I'm tracing how this myth
has changed in its apprehension over time.
So in part, I'm trying to rediscover
the ways in which these myths
have a kind of sedimented construction,
so that when we call somebody
today a modern day Medea,
as we did Andrea Yates in the early 2000s,
that's the woman who was diagnosed with,
I think she was diagnosed
with psychosis, in Texas,
and whose family believed
that her most important duty
was to have children, so
she had five children,
even though her medical doctor
said that that was not
a great choice for her,
and she drowned them all in the bathtub.
And she was called a modern day Medea.
What I'm really interested in there is,
does that not seem to imply
that Medea is premodern,
or that we are no longer barbaric,
we no longer kill our children,
but people before killed their children?
And yet infanticide is a component,
a feature of our society as it
has been a feature of society
in different dimensions and
in different ways per society.
So that's how I would say,
is that we're sort of
doing both of those things.
And I'm asking you to think
about the ways in which
you believe that that
pushing violence out there
is the right way to treat violence,
when it always comes back.
Is there another way to treat it,
would be my sort of understanding
of how we should think about that today.
- So you're not giving us a manifesto,
but you are saying we can
learn a lot from Medea.
- I am. I am.
(Juliette laughs)
- Yeah.
I'm sold, I'm sold.
- [Juliette] Thank you! (laughs)
- Okay, next question.
"Fantastic talk."
- Thank you.
- "Was Medea a big deal onstage
in other national contexts
in the 17th century, England
or Spain, for example,
or was it a particularly French
obsession, and if so, why?"
- I am so sorry that I
am not as well-versed
in that question as I wish I were.
I do know that there are
"Medeas" in the Italian,
and there are "Medeas" in Spanish,
and I'm embarrassed to say
that I know very little
about English tragedy
other than what was given to me
in the New York public school system.
(laughing) And I don't know, though,
the question asks, "the
obsession in France,"
I don't think France was obsessed with it,
and I think we can trace
what I call a Medean violence
in any culture.
And that is to say, attempts
at eliminating violence
that then transmute that
violence into another quality
to allow that violence to return
and have a certain kind
of effect on society.
So I'm gonna hazard a guess
to that person
that if the theme of Medea is not there,
we could trace a Medean violence.
I wish there were an expert
in any of those traditions
in attendance who could tell us.
That's how I
- Yeah,
- would answer that.
- I'm looking.
Q and A folks, please write in.
Maybe you could say a little bit
about these modern Medea representations.
So you mentioned the fantastic Pasolini,
and you showed us an
image of Maria Callas.
How do they express,
I mean, how do they speak
to you, those two figures?
- So I will say that the Sophie Deraspe,
but I'm just gonna talk
about the "Antigone,"
because I've been Antigone-bashing
for quite a bit here,
but I want to recover Sophie
Deraspe's "Antigone" from 2019,
which does everything I say
that our use of Antigone doesn't do,
that the Antigone effect occludes.
Deraspe's Antigone is an immigrant.
It's a Quebecois film, she's an immigrant.
She is working class,
and she takes on an entire system
in the name of her brother.
The hoops are not big
that one has to jump
through to imagine that.
And so I'm not saying that
a figure like Antigone
is not recoverable or
could not be transformed.
What I'm saying is what we
usually do with Antigone
is something that's very different,
by focusing mostly on
her contestatory words.
The Pasolini movie
I think is really
remarkable because it also
strives to consider how
important history is
and how important knowledge is.
So one of the things I've
tried to insist on in this talk
is that I think that the
foreigner is a foreigner
because of what they know
and how their knowledge
is scary and potent
and not controllable,
and Pasolini does a wonderful job
of putting those tensions into play,
including in his
consideration of how history
works on children and adults
and how lessons are transmitted,
transferred to generation to generation.
The other thing I'll say
about Pasolini's "Medea,"
if you haven't seen it, you
should run and go see it,
because it's Maria Callas
who's playing Medea,
and she is silent.
The diva of opera is
silent for like 13 minutes.
The first 13 minutes of the
film, you hear her say nothing.
I can't remember, it's not 13 minutes,
I can't remember how long it is,
but for an incredibly
long part of this film,
she says absolutely nothing.
And the film begins with
these atonal music that
is in such contrast
to who we think we see.
The other thing is that
I think Callas was in her
mid 30s, so absolutely aged,
and this Medea is offered
as this aged person, and-
- The aged witch.
- The aged witch, and I think
that that's really important.
So I think that that's
quite, quite remarkable.
I could name a few other
really remarkable "Medeas."
- Yeah, give us some suggestions.
- Okay.
So, I will say
that the Deborah Warner "Medea"
that was starring Fiona Shaw
is probably one of the best
known contemporary productions,
and it is, the acting is sublime,
and I think it's a
terrible interpretation.
It's a beautiful play,
it's a beautiful play.
I cried, I absolutely loved,
it's a wonderful production,
but in an interview,
Fiona Shaw and Deborah Warner both said
that "Medea" is a play about divorce,
which is very interesting.
If you read the "Medea"
play, it's about, you know,
it's possible to think about it
as couple folks splitting up,
and so they're gonna argue
about the kids and...
- [Alice] Yeah.
- And that's it.
But I think that what that really occludes
is the asymmetry in the play
between Jason and Medea,
and Warner's play does think about that,
but it really evacuates the
political contestation, and-
- So it becomes like Kramer and Kramer.
- "Kramer vs. Kramer," right.
And I don't wanna, I don't,
I wanna cool how phenomenal
that production was
with a difference I have
in its interpretation,
that if you want to see "Medea"
as a play about divorce,
that is a phenomenal play.
And I'm thinking, I'm sort
of blanking, I should've-
- No, no, that's okay.
- There's a Rachel Cusk
version of it in which,
which is very, very controversial,
I think was that one at the
Court Theatre in London,
which is very controversial,
in which Medea doesn't kill
her children, they overdose.
And this was seen as incredible violence
to the Euripides.
And I do, I do think that we
should maybe stop policing
our interpretations of
classical tragedies,
because I think that
that is one thing about
classical tragedies,
is that they are speaking to the problems,
the intractable problems
of life in this world with other people.
I think that that is
one of the most powerful
things about that.
So a reinvention of any of these tragedies
is always a good thing.
- Always welcome.
- Yes, always welcome.
- Okay, I think we have
time for one more question.
Let's see, "I understand why
the killing of her children
is the episode that has stuck
in our collective minds,
but were all her other
gruesome means of violence,
the burning, the herbs, the
poisoned cloak, and more
components of the 17th
century staged versions?"
- So I would just like to say one thing,
that the killing of the
children is something
that happens in the ancient
Greek version of it,
and that's why we have it,
that's that innovation.
Before that, classicist scholars tell me,
it is the Corinthian
women, or the Corinthians,
who kill the children
and blame it on Medea.
So part of the tragedy is to
make Medea kill her children.
- Oh, wow.
- To concentrate that
violence into one character.
So I think that that's really important.
Her other gruesome means of violence,
the burning, the herbs,
the poisoned cloak,
and the other components
are very much part of the
17th century staged version,
and in fact, Pierre Corneille
spends a lot of time
really trying, and he
says this in his preface,
that he really wants
to even out the guilt,
even out the burden among
the different characters,
and in his version, Creusa is this,
she's avide, she's
materialistic, she's grabby.
She asks for the coat, and she says,
"You know what I'd really like?
I'll spare the children's lives
if you get me her coat," to Jason.
And she asks for it,
and Medea says, "Okay.
You want my coat?
I will give you my coat,
and I will give you more."
And I have an argument in
the book about that coat,
but there's a way in which
Corneille actually wants
to distribute blame.
He's not interested in
concentrating all of that
into the Medea figure,
which I find really
interesting and really telling.
The violence and the
poisoned coat and the burning
are all part of most myths,
and one thing I'll say for folks
who are interested in this,
just one little thing,
is that in the premodern period,
there are two Medea versions.
There's the Medea who burns down Corinth
and kills her husband's new fiancee,
burns down the city, rather,
kills her husband's fiancee,
and rides off,
but there's also the passionate one,
the one who helps Jason
take the Golden Fleece.
And often-
- Yeah, the love affair.
- The love, the love.
And you see those on cassone,
on Italian dowry chests,
you see Jason and the Golden Fleece,
Jason and Medea and the Golden Fleece
on wedding dowry chests,
and you see that in frescoes
celebrating marriages.
And in the premodern period,
there's no contradiction
between those two,
those two versions of Medea
can be held simultaneously.
That comes from Ovid, by the way though,
that's from Ovid.
- That's very interesting.
I think that's a great way to end
and whet our appetite for
reading "In the Wake of Medea:
Tragedy and the Arts of Destruction
in Neoclassical France."
That was fantastic.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you all.
Thank you for coming.
And thank you so much for
this great opportunity.